>> Tucker: "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER AMY SPENT MORE TIME
COVERING HILLARY CLINTON
THAN ANY LIVING PERSON.
THROUGH TWO PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGNS AND A DECADE SHE
HAS A NEW BOOK OUT CALLED
CHASING HILLARY, 10 YEARS,
TWO CAMPAIGNS ONE INTACT
GLASS CEILING DESCRIBE AS
LOT ABOUT HILLARY PROFANE
TIRADES AGAINST TRUMP.
WHOP DER HOW MANY MEN
ACCUSED OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SURROUNDED CLINTON.
SHE SAYS SHE WAS BY HILLARY.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU HAVE TAKEN GRIEF FOR
THIS BOOK FROM THE RIGHT
THAT SAYS YOU CONCEDE IN THE
BOOK THAT HAD YOU AFFINITY
FOR HILLARY, YOU SHARE HER
POLITICS.
I WANT TO SAY AT THE OUTSET
I LIKE THE FACT THAT YOU
WERE HONEST ABOUT IT UNLIKE
A LOT OF REPORTERS YOU HAVE
TO GUESS.
YOU WERE DIRECT AND I
APPRECIATE IT GIVEN THAT THE
MILLER PEOPLE ARE SNIPING
ABOUT YOU AND COMPLAINING
ABOUT YOU LIKE YOU ARE THE
PROBLEM.
WHY?
SEEMS TO SAY A LOT ABOUT
THEM.
>> EXACTLY.
APPARENTLY THIS IS THE BOOK
THAT THE CLINTONS DON'T WANT
YOU TO READ.
AS YOU POINT OUT IT IS
PARTLY SYMPATHETIC TO HER.
I ANTICIPATED THE BLOW BACK.
PART OF WHAT I GET INTO IN
THE BOOK IS THAT THERE IS NO
GRAY AREA FOR HILLARY
CLINTON, YOU ARE EITHER
COMPLETELY DEVOTED TO HER OR
AN ENEMY.
A LOT OF THE TIME MY
COVERAGE WAS IN BETWEEN.
AND SOMETIMES I WROTE SOME
TOUGH STORIES.
I WAS THE BEAT REPORTER
COVERING THIS CAMPAIGN DAY
IN AND DAY OUT.
SO, YOU KNOW, THERE WASN'T A
LOT OF GRAY AREA.
YOU WERE EITHER THE ENEMY OR
YOU WERE, YOU KNOW,
COMPLETELY DEVOTED.
>> Tucker: BUT I MEAN, HOW
SORT OF OUT OF IT DO YOU
HAVE TO BE AND I KNOW THE
CLINTON PEOPLE FEEL THIS WAY
THINK THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
IS TOO RIGHT WING TO COVER
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY HAVE SAID THAT TO ME SO
I KNOW THEY ACTUALLY FEEL
THAT WAY.
WHAT PLANET ARE THEY ON.
>> THEY ARE ON PLANET
HILLARY WHICH I HAVE WRITTEN
ABOUT EXTENSIVELY.
ONE OF THE THEMES IN THE
BOOK THAT YOUR VIEWERS WILL
FIND SURPRISING DECADES LONG
BATTLE BETWEEN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" AND THE CLINTON CAMP,
SOMETHING I WAS MY EABOUT
WHEN I WAS PUT ON THE BEAT
IN 2013.
I HADN'T ANTICIPATED THAT
HER AIDS WOULD ESSENTIALLY
BLAME ME FOR THE WHITE WATER
SCANDAL WHICH, TUCKER,
HAPPENED WHEN I WAS 12.
BUT THERE IS ALL THIS WHICH,
OF COURSE, THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" BROKE.
THERE IS ALL THIS BAD BLOOD
PASSED ON BETWEEN THE CLINTS
AND "NEW YORK TIMES" FROM
GENERATION TO GENERATION OF
WHICH I WAS A RECIPIENT PUT
ON HER 2016 CAMPAIGN.
I THINK IT WOULD SURPRISE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT THAT AN
NO,
AN,
ANIMOSITY EXISTS.
>> Tucker: CHELSEA IS MAD AT
AT YOU.
>> CHELSEA SENT 30 TWEETS IN
THE PAST FEW DAYS
CRITICIZING SOME OF MY
REPORTING.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
SO YOU SAID IN THE BOOK I
THINK I KNEW THIS
OVERWHELMING BEAT REPORTER
COVERING HILLARY WAS A
WOMEN.
HILLARY WAS RUNNING A
CAMPAIGN IF SHE
CAMPAIGN SF SHE
CAMPAIGN SHESHE
CAMPAIGN SHE WE
CAMPAIGN SHE WAS A WOMAN:
YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND OF
STACK AGO DECK A LITTLE BIT.
DO YOU SEE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT ARRANGEMENT?
>> THAT'S INTERESTING.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS IN
THE BOOK THAT I POINTS OUT
IS LIKE HILLARY ACTUALLY
LIKED THE GUYS.
LIKE YOUR VERY OWN ED HENRY
WOULD GRILL HER ABOUT OTHER
EMAILS AND SHE KIND OF
LIKED -- SHE LIKED THE
BANTER WITH HIM.
SHE WAS FLIRTY WITH SOME OF
THE GUYS.
I DON'T THINK THERE WAS A
PARTICULAR LIKE LOVE FEST
BECAUSE WOMEN WERE COVERING
HER.
IF ANYTHING, I THINK THERE
WAS THE PERCEPTION THAT
WOMEN MIGHT BE TOUGHER ON
HER TO KIND OF PROVE, YOU
KNOW, THE COUNTER TO YOUR
POINT.
TO PROVE WE WEREN'T IN THE
TANK.
>> Tucker: IS SHE THE FIRST
SELF-DESCRIBED FEMINIST YOU
HAVE EVER MET HARDER ON
>> I CANNOT ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
>> Tucker: I THINK WE BOTH